una presunta ejecución extrajudicial así
catalogan autoridades y medios de prensa
El último hecho de violencia registrado
en la ciudad mexicana de Nuevo Laredo un
video captado por una cámara de
seguridad muestra una persecución que
resulta en un accidente automovilístico
segundos después una decena de soldados
se acerca la auto accidentado en el que
circulaban un grupo de civiles
supuestamente armados y proceden a
detenerlos los presuntos delincuentes
son golpeados y colocados estando
inmovilizados contra una cerca
perimetral luego se ve como los
uniformados abren fuego contra un
enemigo invisible pues no se ve en el
cuadro de la imagen al final los
detenidos terminan muertos solo uno
sobrevivió pero falleció más tarde por
sus heridas los hechos ocurrieron el
pasado 18 de mayo al parecer
si hubo ajusticiamiento
y eso no se puede permitir nosotros no
somos iguales
a los anteriores gobiernos Entonces
cuando hay un abuso cuando hay un exceso
cuando se violan Derechos Humanos
tiene que
castigarse a los responsables el martes
en la secretaría de defensa nacional
informó que la fiscalía general de la
república llevaría el peso de las
investigaciones al estar involucrados
civiles la fiscalía general de Justicia
militar en el ámbito de su competencia
desde el momento que se dio a conocer
este material bibliográfico editado
inició de oficio una investigación de
los hechos para deslindar las
responsabilidades derivadas de la
legislación militar no es la primera vez
que Nuevo Laredo es escenario de un
hecho de violencia similar cuatro meses
antes cinco jóvenes fueron asesinados y
uno quedó mal herido al ser
interceptados por uniformados